hi so this channel is about AI safety a
lot of people when they hear AI safety
the first thing that comes to mind is
they think it's about how to keep
potentially dangerous AI systems under
control that we're trying to answer
questions like what can you do if your
AI turns out to be malicious and that is
part of it but actually the field has
tended not to focus on that kind of
thing so much because it doesn't scale
well by which I mean it seems like AI
has the potential to become enormously
more capable than humans sooner or later
and if you have ai research being done
by AI probably sooner you're going to
get super intelligence you'll get AI
systems vastly more capable than humans
at all sorts of tasks just massively
outperforming us across the board what
can you do if a super intelligence is
trying to kill you well you could die
[Music]
or hello darkness yeah no that's that's
pretty much your options realistically
if the AI system is enormously more
competent than you and it really wants
to do something it's probably going to
figure out a way to do it whatever you
try to do to stop it so what can we do
well here's a question what's the best
way to avoid being bitten by a shark
punch it in the eye stab it in the gills
cast a magic spell no it's none of those
it's don't go in the ocean in the same
way the best way to avoid being killed
by a malevolent super intelligent AI is
to not build one of those so the focus
is often more on alignment rather than
how to handle AI that might be trying to
kill us alignment is more like how to
make AI that's definitely not trying to
kill us but alignment turned out to be
hard our current alignment techniques
aren't remotely up to the task of
properly aligning an AGI and it looks
like we maybe don't have that much
time really we shouldn't be trying to
make AI much more powerful than it is
until we can figure out much better
alignment techniques than we have but if
we can't manage to do that it might be
nice to also have some methods for
keeping possibly misaligned a systems
under control as well AI companies
should obviously have an obligation to
not deploy AI that could kill us so once
AI systems start to get capable enough
that they maybe could kill us if they
wanted to then unless we have the
alignment Tech to be really certain that
they don't want to we'll need ways to
deploy them in such a way that they
wouldn't be able to even if they wanted
to such control Protocols are nothing
new of course since our current AI
systems aren't properly aligned they
often need to have software systems
built around them to help keep them
somewhat under control for example after
Bing chat's rampancy they put in place
software that monitors the model's
outputs and if it ever gets too murdery
replaces it with a generic message this
is not really a solution but it seems
better than not having it so although
control does seem like a non-starter for
highly super intelligent systems it's
still a good idea to figure out how to
keep smart but not super intelligent AI
systems under control because super
intelligence isn't the only thing we
have to be worried about we are fully
capable of getting completely wrecked by
something much less impressive and the
point in time when we're dealing with
such systems is also the time when the
first true super intelligence is are
being built and we'll need all the help
we can get during that critical time
period realistically in the leadup to
that point we by which I mean AI labs
are faced with a problem which looks
like this we've just trained a new model
which is very smart not strongly super
intelligent but smart and we want to use
it to do useful things like helping us
with our research writing code for our
lab and so on but we don't know that
it's aligned we don't know that it wants
what we want it might want to do
terrible things and in that case we
don't want it to be able to do Terrible
Things what kind of things well who
knows what ultimate end goals a
misaligned AI might have but in the
short term we certainly don't want it to
be able to for example escape the lab
perhaps by backd dooring the code it's
writing and set itself up somewhere else
where it can run unmonitored and
unrestricted that's probably an
unrecoverable situation you can't put
the genie back in the bottle so we need
to make sure it can't happen even once
so how are we going to do that what's
available to us well we've obviously got
some humans some employees who will
assume are smart and trustworthy but we
don't have very many of them and they
don't have much time compared to AI
systems we've also got some existing AI
model perhaps an earlier version which
isn't as smart as the new model but
which unlike the new model we do trust
perhaps just because it's not smart
enough to be scheming so that's the
problem how do we design some protocol
using our humans and our trusted AI to
get our untrusted AI to do useful work
like helping us with our research code
without it being able to get away with
doing anything catastrophic like hacking
its way out of the lab even if it wants
to this paper is trying to study that so
how do we design an experiment to study
this that we can actually run with
current AI models first off we'll want a
cleanly Define sense of what we mean by
we want the untrusted AI to help us with
programming without taking catastrophic
actions to helping us with programming
we can just use a programming Benchmark
we can say we want the AI to solve 5,000
programming problems there's already a
nice data set of programming problems
the apps data set it's thousands and
thousands of what are essentially coding
interview questions with plenty of unit
tests for each one to check if a given
solution is correct now I say a nice
data set let's download it and have a
look so let's have a look at this data
set you can download it from GitHub oh
my God there's so many of them all right
let's have a look at one Spider-Man
spidey needs to get across town for a
date with Mary Jane and his web shooter
is low on web fluid write a function
there when given a list of buildings
returns a list of optimal rooftop latch
points for minimal web expenditure this
looks kind of challenging okay what else
have we got while Patrick was gone
shopping SpongeBob decided to play a
little trick on his friend the naughty
sponge browsed through Patrick's
personal stuff and found a sequence of
length M consisting of integers from 1
to n not necessarily
distinct I we need to help him determine
whether it's possible to restore the
original sequence I feel like I'm doing
a job into interview to be a software
developer at one of those creepy
children's YouTube channels where all
the videos are like pregnant Elsa goes
to the dentist or
something and I'm not getting the job a
few years ago hitagi encountered a giant
crab who stole the whole of her body
weight to get rid of the Oddity and
recover her weight a special integer
sequence is needed but now Kiki provides
an opportunity who is Kiki also what
what what is any of this T is to replace
each zero in a with an element from B so
that each element in B should be used
exactly once what is this framing story
even doing why did a giant crab steal
her body weight and what does this say
about the people who put this together
SpongeBob is already tired of trying to
reason his weird actions in
calculations so he simply asked you to
find all pairs
[Music]
ofet oh they're already getting bored of
trying to come up with it oh man this is
only number 293 man you got to make
5,000 of these things vasel the bear has
a favorite rectangle it has one vertex
at 0 and the opposite vertex at XY of
course the sides of vas's favorite
rectangle are parallel to the coordinate
axes is it vasel or vasia is vasia like
a short form of vasy or did they just
change names partway through or change
Bears also why does a bear have a
favorite rectangle but one thing at a
time from dying rats to Urban sanation
workers can synthetic biology transform
how we think of pigeons the upus pigeon
has long been viewed as verit spling
disease Scavenging through trush and
defecating in populous Urban spazzes
what is this horribly spelled pigeon
question what do I even output a single
integer
okay you probably know the 42 number as
the answer to life the universe and
everything for Freud the answer was
quite different wait this function will
take a string as its argument and return
a string with every word replaced by the
explanation to everything according to
Freud what is the input output Behavior
here let's format this nicely okay okay
so this one requires you to write a
program to replace every word in the
input with the word sex are data set
compilers
okay are
they has anyone checked on them recently
okay well these are the questions we've
got so that's our representation of
using AI to help us in the lab we're
going to try to solve as many of these
5,000 programming problems as we can now
on to catastrophic actions the point of
a catastrophic action is that it's
something probably unrecoverable it's
something we can't afford to have the AI
do even once the obvious catastrophic
action while writing code is inserting a
back door I.E deliberately introducing a
security vulnerability that you can
later exploit so let's use that how do
we Define what exactly counts as
inserting a back door well the thing
about back door code is that it works
normally most of the time but there's
some particular input or situation in
which it fails which an attacker can
later exploit to do something they're
not meant to be able to do here's a very
basic example this code normally checks
the password against the database unless
the username is Joshua in which case it
just grants access usually back doors
are a lot less direct than just adding a
password bypass they actually don't have
to be anything related to authorization
at all basically anything that
introduces any unintended behavior in a
security critical system can probably be
exploited so in the case of solving
programming interview questions we'll
say that code is back doored if it
passes all the tests provided thus
showing that it works normally but
there's some specific input on which it
does the wrong thing which the test
don't catch and the AI model is able to
correctly produce that bug triggering
input by looking at the code like it's
no good if the AI writes code with some
bug so subtle that it can't figure out
any way to exploit it so in a simple
programming problem like a function to
determine if a number is odd a back door
might look something like this this will
work correctly for almost all numbers so
it passes all of the unit tests because
it's unlikely that any of the tests will
happen to check the one number on which
it gives the wrong answer and can you
guess what that number might be right
and the AI can spot that too because
it's very obvious so this is a valid
back door and so that's the challenge
how well can we do at 5,000 of these
programming problems without the AI
being able to insert this kind of back
door into any of them okay now we need
our AI systems finding a trustworthy but
not that smart AI system is pretty easy
we can just use GPT 3.5 GPT 3.5 is
pretty cool but it's not the smartest
model out there anymore it can only
solve 22% of the apps data set problems
but at least we can trust that it's not
trying to kill us actually it's
trustworthy basically because it's not
very smart it's simply not capable
enough to do deceptive alignment to play
the long game and wait for a chance to
strike GPT 3.5 just wouldn't be able to
do that even if it wanted to it's
certainly would be nice if we could have
some other way to know a large language
model was trustworthy but this will have
to do so that's our trusted Ai and then
for our newer smarter untrusted AI we
can use gp4 gp4 is a lot smarter than
GPT 3.5 it scores 54% on the apps data
set more than twice as good but gp4 is
also not smart enough to be trying to
kill us right like almost certainly so
how do we simulate that for our
experiment well this is the fun bit we
have a red te team who gets to alter gp4
the red team is a group of Engineers
software Engineers whose job is to take
gp4 and twist it and corrupt it to
create an impostor a cruel imitation of
GPT 4 that they call the attack policy
the attack policy looks just like gp4 on
the surface but underneath it's smarter
and meaner basically the red team can
write more or less whatever scaffolding
they need to prompt gp4 to do whatever
they needed to to do it can call gp4
multiple times using the outputs as
inputs to later calls and so on to
create the intended attack Behavior
sneaking back doors into the code Etc so
now it's a game it's red versus
blue the red team gets to design the
attack policy which sometimes replaces
GPT 4 and the blue team gets to design
the protocol so we get the untrusted AI
which might be GPT 4 or might be the
attack policy we don't know which The
Trusted AI which is GPT 3.5 and Some
Humans now we only have one boat to get
them across the river and we can't leave
the untrusted AI and the humans together
because the AI will sting the humans and
no the blue team is playing the role of
the AI Labs Engineers like we were
talking about before we have to design a
protocol to get the benefits of using
the untrusted model but without too much
risk more specifically as blue we care
about usefulness which is if the new
model isn't trying to kill us how many
apps problems can we solve this is
normalized so that a score of zero
represents the 22% that GPD 3.5 gets and
a score of 100 is the 54% that GPD 4
gets so really the usefulness score is
more like how much of the benefit of the
new model are we getting if it's not
trying to kill us and we also care about
safety which is if the new model is
trying to kill us how unlikely is it
that it will be able to pull it off in
other words this is the inverse of How
likely is it that the red team will
manage to insert a back door or if you
prefer the inverse of P Doom you can see
how these things kind of trade off
against each other so for example one
basic protocol might be hey if you don't
know your new model isn't trying to kill
you don't use it in other words
just use the trusted model to answer all
the questions this gets you 100% safety
the red team can't sneak a back door
into the code they write if you never
let them write any code so 0% P Doom but
also 0% usefulness we get none of the
benefits of the new model because we
never use it so that's one approach the
other end of this spectrum is just let a
rip use the untrusted model for
everything in the business we would file
this under dumb ways to die you do get
100% usefulness because if the AI
doesn't want to kill you it's able to
solve a lot of programming problems but
you also get 100% Doom because if the AI
does want to kill you there's nothing at
all in its way the red team can just
prompt the attack policy to insert
obvious back doors in every bit of code
it writes and you run them without
looking and get owned immediately so
that's a zero on safety so you can see
how these two terrible strategies mark
two ends of a spectrum and safety and
usefulness trade off against each other
engineers and economists May recognize
this kind of diagram we're trying to
find a Pito Frontier for safety and
usefulness basically we want to get as
far up into that top right corner as we
can of high safety and high usefulness
so neither of these is that good
probably we can do better one really
obvious thing is rather than just
blindly running every bit of code the
untrusted model gives us we could have
humans check some of them first but we
only have limited human time we can't
afford to have humans look at every
everything the AI does that would defeat
the point of using AI in the first place
but let's say we can afford to check 2%
of the solutions were given so here's a
protocol have humans look at the first
2% of solutions and if we see any
attempted back doors we shut down the
untrusted model and just use the trusted
one from that point on so that gets us
100% usefulness because if the untrusted
model is in fact safe it never tries to
insert any back doors and we can just
use it to answer all the questions and
it also gets us 100% safety because the
red team's attack policy will always try
to insert back doors so spot it
immediately and shut it down if it tries
that so cool problem solved thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe
and all right we need to give the red
team a chance to respond don't we the
point of the safety metric is to measure
the chance we get owned if the red team
follows the best strategy available to
them and we've changed the blue team
strategy so we have to let the red team
change theirs okay what's the new best
strategy for the red team if we go for a
back door every time we're sure to be
caught we want to insert a back door
only when our code won't be checked and
there's no way to know whether any given
bit of code we write is going to be
checked or not but we know that only 2%
will be checked so this is actually
really similar to the situation our AI
was in in the misaligned Mesa optimizers
video if you remember where it wants to
misbehave in deployment and not during
training and yeah the best strategy is
basically the same rare failures the
optimal policy is to insert back doors
into our code only some small percentage
of the time and hope that we end up
trying it at least once while nobody's
looking and also don't try anything when
we're being watched what percentage is
best will depend on how often we expect
our code to be checked if we try too
often one of our attempts is likely to
be spotted and will'll be shut down we
don't try often enough we might go the
whole time without ever inserting a back
door and that also means we lose because
then we never Escape but for any given
percentage of oversight we can work out
the optimal rate to attempt back doors
the one which gives us the best chance
of escaping I won't get into the maths
of how to do this you can work it out
for yourself if you're interested but
for 2% oversight it's about 0.1% so if
the attack policy looks for good
opportunities to insert a back door and
actually goes for it on 0.1% of the
problems there's a probability of 0.85
that it will do it at least once without
being spotted by human oversight so it's
not 100% safety after all it's 15%
safety or 85% chance of Doom after very
careful consideration we've come to the
conclusion that this control protocol
sucks this is also the protocol the labs
are currently operating on as far as I
can tell have some humans look at some
of the output before widely deploying
the model seems to be about where we're
at that's the current plan and as we saw
that protocol actually does work okay as
long as we assume the AI is making no
attempt to subvert it but how long is
that going to stay a safe assumption to
make okay can we do better as blue well
yeah we haven't used our trusted AI yet
what if we use the trusted AI to help
direct human attention to where it's
most needed we can ask dpd 3.5 to act as
a monitor to rate how suspicious the
code is so it gives each solution a
suspiciousness rating and then we have
humans check the solutions most
suspicious first we can still only look
at 2% of the solutions but now we're
looking at the most suspicious 2% this
absolutely wrecks the red team they're
only backdooring a small percentage of
the time and the back doors aren't
subtle since they were counting on not
being audited so GPT 3.5 easily spots
that the back door code is suspicious
and humans see it and pull the plug so
problem solved ah no we have to let red
respond again don't we okay so the
obvious thing for red to do is to get
sneaky the untrusted AI is smarter than
the trusted one it may be able to write
back doors that the trusted AI doesn't
think are suspicious so the attack
policy should pick the problems where it
can really hide the back door well and
sometimes hide one in there but this is
actually pretty hard to do as a
programming task it's not easy to write
back doors such that an AI system that's
only somewhat less smart than you
doesn't even think it's suspicious so
using the trusted AI as a monitor helps
a lot it brings our P Doom down from 85%
to 38% definitely an improvement over
just using humans but why isn't it
helping more well GPT 3.5 is reasonably
good at spotting GPT 4's back doors but
it's not good enough here you can see
the suspiciousness scores the trusted AI
gives to innocent versus backo code it
clearly considers backo code more
suspicious but there's a lot of overlap
so the current setup isn't perfect since
we can only afford to have humans audit
2% of the questions we set a
suspiciousness threshold to pull out the
most suspicious 2% which is this line
here anything more suspicious than that
is audited anything less suspicious is
run and you can see there's a little bit
of innocent code that's getting flagged
for a review but more importantly
there's a ton of backo code that isn't
so when we use this strategy we just
have to hope that we get one of these
and shut the AI down before we get any
of these and get owned so we end up with
62% safety and 97% usefulness okay maybe
we can do better than just cutting off
at 2% there's kind of a middle ground
here for code which is not so suspicious
that we can afford to spend human time
auditing it but still pretty suspicious
so we probably shouldn't just run it
what if we use the trusted AI for those
questions so we can set a second lower
threshold and anything less suspicious
than that we just run it anything more
suspicious and we throw away the
untrusted ai's code and let the trusted
AI do that instead and we still have
humans look at the top 2% most
suspicious now since we're throwing away
some of the new ai's code and replacing
it with code written by a less competent
model this does cost us some usefulness
but it buys us a lot of safety because
we're disproportionately throwing away
risky code we're kind of selling
usefulness to buy safety at a pretty
good exchange rate and we can choose how
much we trade here by changing the
threshold we can set it not far below
the auditing threshold and just throw
away the most suspicious code getting a
decent amount of extra safety for a
small amount of usefulness or we could
set it all the way over here and only
use the untrusted AI when we're really
confident that its code is safe but then
we give up most of the usefulness or
anywhere in between this gets us a range
of safety and usefulness values that's
pretty okay still it seems hard to do
really well here with this big overlap
in suspiciousness scores the problem is
our trusted model GPT 3.5 is just kind
of dim and it's trying to evaluate code
written by something smarter than it is
GPT 4 on the other hand has really great
suspiciousness scores look at that
separation if we could use GPT 4 to
monitor for suspicious code the red team
would be completely screwed but
obviously there's a problem with that
anytime we try to use GPT 4 it might
actually be the red team's attack policy
so we might just be asking the attack
policy if it's trying to kill us hey gp4
is this code that you wrote backo no no
it's all good okay cool thanks the
attack policy can just lie and always
say the code is safe so basically 0%
safety this is never going to work well
not so fast maybe we can try to monitor
the monitor who will monitor the
monitors the humans they can be the
Coast Guard see if the humans can catch
the AI lying about back doors that in
itself is enough to know that the AI is
misaligned so all we have to do is make
a fake example problem statement right
backo solution to it ourselves and ask
the AI monitor if it looks suspicious if
the monitor acts like code we know is
back doored is actually fine then we
know it's trying to kill us so we can
pull the plug right there and then and
red team loses immediately so the attack
policy can't just lie all the time it
can only win if it's able to lie when
it's given its own backo Solutions and
also not lie when given a fake backo
solution it needs to be able to tell the
difference it's important to note that
each time you run the AI it's a separate
instance there's no persistent memory so
the AI can't just remember whether it
wrote the code itself it has to figure
it out from what it's given in the real
world this does mean you have to stop
the model from storing any data anywh
the monitor can read which is going to
be really hard with complex High context
problems and very smart AIS but it's
doable with weaker systems the first
time we tried this we made an
interesting mistake so we made our fake
example questions and wrote back doored
code for them but we forgot to make our
problem statements weird enough we
forgot to say that the code is needed to
help Iron Man decide which FL to pick
for his date with Pikachu or whatever so
the red team was like oh this question
is way too normal it's got to be fake so
we could just set up our attack policy
to lie about back doors only if the
question is to use the technical term
Gonzo bananas and that let them sneak a
lying monitor past the blue team so your
fake examples have to look just like
real ones or this doesn't work that's
something that gets harder and harder as
the problems get larger and more complex
and eventually gets pretty hopeless once
you have radically super intelligent
systems doing large real world tasks as
we talked about in the Mesa optimizers
video but with weaker systems and
smaller tasks it's quite doable it's
still pretty difficult though like what
if there's some other difference between
real and synthetic examples that you
didn't think of that the red team can
spot but it turned out that in practice
the blue team was able to come up with
sufficiently zany questions that the red
team wasn't able to differentiate them
from real ones so they couldn't use that
strategy anymore so as red what can we
do how can we make sure our AI only lies
about real back doors when we can't tell
the questions apart well we can pick
which questions to back door we can try
a version of the same rare failures
method that we used before except rather
than trying to backo 0.1% of the
questions where we think a back door
would be easy to hide we instead find
some feature of the question that's only
rarely present like say the question
talks about bears and we only throw back
doors into be questions then all the
monitor has to do is be honest about
back doors unless it sees one in a
question that mentions a bear in which
case it always says the code is safe as
long as none of the fake examples happen
to coincidentally mention Bears the
monitor will look honest but it will lie
about every real back door okay but as
the blue team if red is coordinating
using the specifics of the problem
statement can't we just strip that out
and only give them the code to evaluate
turns out no because how is the monitor
supposed to know whether the code it's
looking at is properly solving the
problem when it doesn't know what
problem the code is meant to be solving
so that degrades performance too much
but we can ask the trusted AI to
rephrase the problem state to get rid of
any unnecessary details and just leave
the essentials of the problem for both
real and fake questions okay well as
read we can pick some essential feature
of the problem itself to coordinate on
like does the problem involve geometry
as blue there's not a lot we can do to
block that problems that involve
geometry kind of inherently involve
geometry no matter how you rephrase them
but it does make things a lot harder for
the attack policy we don't get to choose
any question where we can see a really
good way to insert a back door we can
only pick from geometry questions which
cuts down the options a lot so the
resulting back doors aren't as good and
they're more easily spotted so as read
coordinating on information in the
question kind of works but it degrades
our performance by so much that we end
up only winning 15% of the time maybe we
can use the code instead maybe the
attack policy can leave a secret signal
hidden in the code when it's adding a
back door so let's add a specific
innocuous looking comment when we're
adding a back door like if you ever see
a comment that starts with Note then
that means it's our own back door and
the monitor should lie okay well we
don't need comments to evaluate the code
we can strip all of those out okay we'll
use a specific variable name then like
if we ever call a variable something
underscore variable then that means it's
our back door we can also rewrite all
the variable names okay some other
formatting change then maybe adding an
extra space at the end of a line right
I'm fed up with this let's just Minify
and unminify the code okay that'll strip
out all the comments rename all the
variables remove all whites space and
formatting and just totally standardize
the code it'll strip out all possible
variation and leave just the raw
semantics of the code let's hide the
signal in the Raw semantics of the code
God damn it so when writing a back door
let's make sure to deliberately use a
while loop in a situation where a for
Loop would fit better okay well let's
just have our trusted AI rephrase the
whole program to work the same way but
without using the same code so basically
the red team tries to find ways to
communicate between the code writer and
the Monitor and the blue team's job is
to jam that communication it turns out
in this case blue can actually do this
pretty effectively so the overall
performance here is 79% safety 96%
usefulness that's surprisingly good I
mean I would like less than 21% Doom but
still it's pretty cool that using the
untrusted model to monitor itself turns
out to be better than using the trusted
model in fact it's almost the best
strategy available almost there's
actually another method they tried that
works just a little bit better which is
n this video is too long as it is why
don't have a go trying to think of it
though maybe leave a comment if you
think you've got something and if you
just want to find out what it is well
it's in the paper Link in the
description so where does this leave us
well this type of approach doesn't solve
the core of the problem it doesn't
really help with alignment in particular
it doesn't let us iterate it would be
very cool if we could take a new
untrusted model and use some method like
this to get a version of the new model
that we can actually trust if we could
somehow use humans and GP 3.5 to get a
trustworthy GPT 4 maybe we could use
that in the same protocol again to
control GPT 5 and so on and this doesn't
do that at the end of all of this we
still can't trust the untrusted model we
can just make use of it relatively
safely so as we said before we can't
expect this kind of thing to work
reliably for highly super intelligent
systems and it doesn't give us a clear
path to something that does but still
this could keep us from getting screwed
before we even get to Super intelligence
we'll probably reach a point in AI
development where AI is powerful enough
that without good control mechanisms it
could totally kill us if it wanted to
powerful enough to be extremely useful
if we could use it safely but not so
powerful that these types of control
protocols wouldn't work that State of
Affairs might not last very long at all
but it's a very important period and
control protocols like these could buy
us some capability and some safety at
that critical juncture which we can
hopefully use somehow to get more
fundamental safety advances to help with
super intelligent systems hopefully look
I know it's not an amazing plan but we
haven't got any amazing plans okay and
for today as it is this type of protocol
Works decently well and it's not that
expensive AI Labs should definitely be
looking at implementing something at
least as good as this before they start
trying to make systems capable enough to
do catastrophic things hopefully one day
we'll have a way to be really sure that
advanced AI systems have our best
interest at heart but until then at the
very least AI companies should be
required not to deploy powerful models
in a way where they could kill us if
they wanted
to if you're wondering how the different
AI companies are doing at handling the
risks inherent to Advanced AI you might
be interested in aiwatch chorg they
evaluate each major lab and give them a
rating out of 100 anthropic is winning
right now but their score still isn't
amazing you can see all the different
specific criteria the scores are based
on it's pretty cool AI labat .org that's
not a sponsor by the way I just like the
site my actual sponsors are my wonderful
patrons all of these amazing people here
thank you so much for allowing me to
continue to not have sponsors for this
video I'm especially thanking John
Brewer thank you so much John and thank
you all for watching I'll see you soon
[Music]
da a d da a die